alright thanks so much you guys see that
was for you dad yeah I need technical
help too this has been great really
seeing everybody show their support and
say such nice things I guess I've been
seeing all the lessons people have
learned from him and that's how i'll be
talking about going about this talk is
i'm going to share chronologically a
series of lessons that I've learned from
my dad dick carp and I hope you guys
learned something too from it so I'll
start off at the very beginning in 1988
and here we are on a nice day in
berkeley and the very first lesson I
learned from him was to take time to
enjoy a nice day so shafi was saying
that he was always really patient in
terms of meeting with students and
wondered whether that translated to his
personal life and I think it does so it
took some time for me to appreciate it
but he always likes going for long walks
and people watching and takes time out
to have a sit-down lunch every single
day regardless of his schedule and I
think in this world you know that's
admirable to not be in a rush and while
he's relaxed and patient he also gets a
lot done and I think he wanted to
translate that to me so we didn't waste
any time and he set me up with some of
the world's best tutors so here I am
getting a lesson in zero knowledge
proofs from Manuel and Lenore Blum and
shortly after they showed me the
analysis of randomized quicksort with
Don Knuth so the lesson here is to again
stealing from cioffi to collaborate and
learn from the people around you but all
that theory is well and good he saw that
computers were not going away and so I
wanted to quickly set me up with some
more applied techniques so here we are
we learned leisure suit larry we learned
kid pix but also i learned unix at a
very young age even though we had ms-dos
and later windows and just a fun fact as
late as 2013
dick was using the command line to check
his university email and insisted that
there was no other way to do it so I'm
not sure about that one but I appreciate
the early computer support and here we
are a couple years later honestly I'm
not sure what the lesson was here but I
think that went over my head but there's
more and I think some more valuable ones
so I'm going to fast forward about 20
years now and I'm in my first year of
graduate school at carnegie mellon
university in pittsburgh and at the time
my research interest was in
approximation algorithms for
combinatorial graph problems and so the
fifth lesson in a slight turn of events
was the held cart paper from 1970 that
traveling salesman problem in minimum
spanning trees and I'm not the only
person at this this workshop to touch on
that I think that's impacted a lot of
people but I want to quickly talk about
a few things and how it remains relevant
to us today so first of all in this
paper the the probably most famous
contribution for it is that they
formulated a linear programming
relaxation for the symmetric traveling
salesman problem and this is known as
the sub 2 or LP now and this in the
approximation algorithms literature
remains very relevant as a starting
point for all kinds of approximation
algorithms for the Traveling Salesman
problem and but at the time this was a
no our paper and so so a lot of it was
about a heuristic they had that used a
Lagrangian method to find a one tree
with the same cost as the sub tour LP
and I went back when preparing for this
talk and looked at the original paper
something I think I'd seen the results
summarize many times but I hadn't
actually read the original 1970 paper
and I saw that they are very proud to
say they have a branch and bound
procedure that uses these lower bounds
to solve instances of up to 60 for
cities to complete optimality and what's
great about this is that these these
first two bullets really you know show
techniques that inform and remain
relevant today but but one thing that
has dramatically changed as computing
power and so I
did a quick google search and I saw that
as of 2007 there's the Concord solver
that can use these techniques as well as
all kinds of fancy cutting planes and
other things to solve traveling salesman
instances optimally with up to 25,000
cities so I hope that that you know
impresses you and and that you see how
your contributions are still informing
us today and the reason I was so
interested in this is at the time I was
working on approximation algorithms to
the graphic TSP problem so that problem
is the Traveling Salesman problem on
shortest path metrics of undirected
unweighted graphs and I was specifically
interested in approximating solutions to
this problem in cubic bipartite graphs
so this these are graphs of degree 3 and
bipartite and so this this class of
graphs allows us to leverage the
structure to get improved approximation
factors but also that keeps much of the
complexity of the original problem and
it also is interesting because it ties
into Barnett's conjecture a conjecture
in structural graph theory that says
that if it's true every bipartite cubic
polyhedron is Hamiltonian and so i'll
explain in a second after showing the
result why why this relates to that so
the the main result is that given a
cubic bipartite graph there's a
polynomial time algorithm that computes
a solution with at most 97 and minus 2
edges and this is joint work with my
advisor are Ravi and so the way we we
obtain this result is we want to find a
cycle cover in the graph with relatively
few cycles so the the general approach
if you're able to do that is you find a
cycle cover with K cycles in your graph
you compress each cycle into a single
node and compute a spanning tree in this
this new grip compressed graph and then
you take your cycle cover and and join
it with two copies of the spanning tree
to get a solution to the Traveling
Salesman problem with n plus 2 K minus 1
edges and so our main result while it
can be viewed as an approximation
algorithm it's also a struck a
constructive proof of a structural
result that any cubic bipartite graph
has a cycle cover with that most in
in over seven cycles and so this is
where it ties back into the Barnett's
conjecture in the sense that you know
that's saying that these graphs or this
more specific class of graphs can be
covered in a single cycle and one way to
make progress towards that is by showing
as that you can cover it with as few
cycles as possible and so it's an
interesting secondary way to view this
this result no more recently my work is
my interest is shifted more towards
operations research and I've been
working on methods and models for
solving optimization problems related to
omni-channel retailing so this this is a
little foreign maybe to the the crowd in
this room but what this really means is
that retailers like whether it's
department stores or Target or Walmart
are selling their products through
multiple channels that could mean they
have physical locations and they also
have an online website and instead of
maintaining a you know completely
separate warehouses to sell their online
products they instead can find savings
by fulfilling online orders directly out
of the retail stores and and so there
are many benefits to this but one of the
challenges that comes with this is that
there's the possibility to overcommit
inventory which leads to the failure of
orders so you can imagine that an item
is listed in the inventory because it's
at several retail locations a customer
orders that item online and then the
clerk goes to pick it up and put it in a
box but someone has purchased that item
in the real physical store or the item
has been moved around or lost and just
in general inventory in physical
locations of brick-and-mortar stores is
less reliable than the inventory in a
dedicated warehouse and so I'm looking
to model and and develop methods to
solve optimization problems that that
work with the trade-off between filling
as many of these orders as possible so
as to get generate revenue while
limiting the costs associated with
orders that fail and so I thought I'd
maybe finally was was done learning
lessons from from my dad but then in the
process of working on one of these
problems i came across
Karpov running father on epaper an
optimal algorithm for online bipartite
matching and this actually is probably
of all the things that that he's done
over the years this one really stuck
with me as a profound and interesting
results so I wanted to share it with you
I think probably half of the room knows
it but it's possible that some of you
don't so you have GU v's a bipartite
graph and the setting is that the V
nodes arrive in an online order while
the you notes are known their end of
each and when a vino derives it must be
matched to an available you knowed upon
arrival and the goal naturally is to get
as large matching as possible and so the
naive algorithm here is is just to match
each node to a random available node but
what what dick and his collaborators did
is they they realized that that's not
going to work out very well what you
need to do is you need to assign all of
the you vertices a random ordered
ranking prior to their arrival of the V
nodes and doing all of this
randomization in one step as a pre
process and then matching each of the
arriving nodes to the highest ranked
neighbor as it arrives gives you a
dramatic improvement so instead of
getting you know at worst and over to
your able to get a matching of size and
over 2 plus big o of log n and in an
expectation and I think this is a really
interesting result and I know that
you're mostly interested in theory but
at the same time you know you couldn't
have predicted google adwords and now
this is a problem that all kinds of
people care about in many different
communities and all of these results are
based off of this paper so that's that's
really neat and also since since i'm i'm
a know our guy i like seeing that in
2007 there's a debonair Jane and
Kleinberg paper that does a primal dual
analysis of this ranking algorithm and
so while I always thought that this
result was really interesting the
analysis in the original paper is a
little difficult to follow at least for
me and it was not necessarily revealed
too much of the intuition for what was
going on in the algorithm but then
there's this this really great simple
primal dual analysis that
ties it into linear programming in a
nice way and and also gives a lot of
intuition into why this algorithm is so
effective and so I'd like to end by
talking about an online problem that I
was working on which led me to
familiarizing myself with this work so
there are a bunch of different ways to
formulate these retail optimization
problems but one way in particular is to
use competitive analysis so you say that
that they're a set of s stores and that
you characterize each order that comes
in by affiliating it with the closest
store to the look odd to where the
customer that's ordering it is located
and then you have to decide when the
order arrives do you accept or reject
this order and and then if you've
accepted the order you're committed to
filling it and you receive a profit
accordingly but also you must decide
which store is going to fulfill it and
pay a shipping costs from that's
corresponding to the distance between
the two stores and also pay a cost based
off of the probability of that order
failing so to formulate that as a math
problem you say there's a shipping cost
metric between the different stores so
shipping an order from store I to J has
cost SI j and if we accept x orders from
store i we receive a profit of x are
representing a fixed profit for each
accepted order but then we also must pay
a cost fi of x for these orders which is
a convex function reflecting that
there's an increased prop marginal
probability of failure for each
additional order that is accepted by
this location and so the orders and
decisions occur in an online stream and
so we want to use competitive analysis
to to work on this problem and we
quickly realize that this is very
related to online matching or allocation
problems because you can think of you
know a nice bipartite graph here or
there are many ways to think of it and
so I guess the the sort of preliminary
result here is that we can see through a
reduction to a combinatorial auction
setting that a simple greedy algorithm
is half competitive here
so the way this this reduction works is
that you think of the the orders or the
items that are being auctioned and the
stores are the bidders and then you can
think of X is some set of orders and you
can define for each store evaluation
function over these sets which
corresponds to the profit that's
generated by filling these orders out of
that store and there's a result from
2001 that says that a greedy algorithm
so where you as the orders come in you
give it to the store that to the bidder
who gains the most marginal utility from
taking this is is half competitive and
and so what's I guess unfortunate for us
is that there there's also a result that
says that no online algorithm randomized
or deterministic is going to do better
than one-half competitive for these
combinatorial auctions with sub modular
valuation functions unless NP is equal
to RP now as Sanjeev Aurora pointed out
this is is four over the class of all
samajh allure functions and there's
we're working to show that to translate
the proof of this this hardness over to
within our specific class evaluation
functions but I can't say with certainty
that that that that's the case but one
thing that were that I'm looking at
going forward is the impact of recourse
on these algorithms so in the in the
real setting where we formulated this
model as the orders arrive you need to
make an immediate decision whether the
retailer accepts or rejects the order
but you may have time before you have to
decide how the order is allocated and so
11 Avenue that I'm pursuing right now is
to see if a better than one-half
competitive algorithm can be formulated
by allowing recourse in this sense then
I'm going to quickly just mention some
of the other topics within this area of
omni-channel optimization that I find
very interesting and I'm currently
pursuing results on so one of them is is
trying to formulate stochastic
optimization problems so instead of this
online setting where you have an
adversary feeding you the orders you can
say that you know
certain prior demand probability
distributions over the demands and try
and solve various sort of news vendor
like optimization problems in this
setting and we've had some I've had some
success of my with my advisors on
solving these formulations but this is
still work in progress and then a nice
extension of this that translates back a
little bit into the the theory community
is is understanding learning rates from
observed data so in reality in it's
unlikely to be known what these
probability distributions of demand for
items are as well as the probability
distributions for order failures and so
one interesting set of problems is where
you have observed data of historical
demands for items and the successor and
failure of of these orders that were
accepted and using that to learn these
rates on the fly and make optimal or
near optimal decisions and there's been
some work in the area of sample average
approximation for trying to use this
historical demand and prove guarantees
of if you want a solution that is within
a certain factor of epsilon close to
optimal with a certain probability upper
bound on the number of samples needed
and but I have some preliminary results
that that I'm developing in this area
and lastly one thing that's very
interesting is we've been working with
several real retailers who have offered
us their data to help them do more
empirical work on this topic and one of
the issues that occurs is that they open
and close these sales channels and as a
consequence they're censoring of the
data because you see that you observe
the demand when the sales channels are
open but as soon as this channels get
closed you're no longer able to to
observe this data and so you need to
apply advanced techniques to be able to
you know understand the impact of the
censoring and how the policy that you're
running over time is affecting the data
that you're collecting and there's
various issues associated with this so
hopefully by carp fest 90 I'll have some
of these problems worked out as well as
others and it'll be
to share them with you so thank you so
much for the lessons dad I hope you're
enjoying the day and continue to enjoy
it so happy birthday so so the data we
were working with we were actually doing
a single store problem so we were doing
we were trying to use features of the
items to predict the cancellation rates
and do a machine learning based approach
on it yeah so that was sort of a
different problem we were working on
thank you